and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists this episode today we're
gonna talk about your dreams Ryan my
American Dream we grew up poor yeah so
when I turned 18 I went out and got the
American Dream yes well I started
pursuing it because there was a lot of
discontent and we were growing up right
and a little bit and I started climbing
the corporate ladder I think I was 22 or
23 when you came aboard the same
corporation you know and we wanted to
live our American Dream together sort of
in parallel right yeah you know so I
didn't really know what the American
dream was but you know knowing about the
template it was so nice to have
something to like shoot for like oh I
just I just need to get a house I need
to be able to buy a new car mm-hmm yeah
I need to have like literally the picket
fence yeah I need to have these things
you need to acquire the stuff and so
today we're gonna talk about the
American Dream what's good about it
what's not so good about it we're
talking about freedom we're talk about
travel maybe give you a little
introduction to minimalism for those of
you who are who are new to the podcast
and you know we're gonna talk about the
unamerican dream as well and we're gonna
answer your questions with today's guest
our good friend Colin Wright is here
who's podcast is called let's know
things and it's available wherever you
listen to podcast Colin I need you to
stop being more handsome than me right
now if you tried I think this is Colin
is is the the perfect guest to have here
in studio because he is he's the person
who basically turned us on to minimalism
in 2009 2010
I remember the videos that you sent me I
think you he was in was he in New
Zealand at the time you might have been
so there was this point where Colin you
you had left your sort of not corporate
gig but but the equivalent of a
corporate gig
you you were you were living in Los
Angeles working a hundred plus hours a
week running a branding studio branding
studio yeah yeah very very different
time and and not the corporate side of
things but the entrepreneurial world has
the similar pipeline where yeah it's the
the work hard play hard thing and you're
told that you're supposed to pursue very
specific metrics of success and in doing
that you realize you were following
someone else's template in a way sort of
a a version of the American Dream and
what's fascinating is you and your
girlfriend at the time realize you
wanted to go separate ways but amicably
and actually really liked each other but
had different aspirations in life and so
you had something called a breakup party
and I remember reading about this and
how radical this was because in our
culture if you break up with someone
it's supposed to be yeah one step below
violent that that's the expectation
we're supposed to yell at each other or
supposed to be mad at each other things
are thrown arguments are had in fact
your breakup party was was the initial
inspiration behind Ryan's packing party
yes because when you you well he gave me
the idea I'm like oh man if you just put
the party yeah at the end of anything
you make it fun that's right people want
to hang out and yeah I have fun with you
and you had an actual breakup party at
midnight you turned your Facebook status
to like single I remember reading about
this and I didn't want your life at all
I saw this thing that was really
aspirational because you left you left
this structure that you walked away from
but then you were you became this
peripatetic writer where you travel to a
new country over four months and where
you went was voted on by the the readers
of your blog Exile lifestyle calm and so
you were in Iceland and New Zealand and
India and South America and all these
other places and I hate traveling and
you owned only 52 items and I'm like
that sucks I want to own a kitchen table
yes and the kitchen table wouldn't fit
in the bag no no I doesn't go in the
overhead bin very well I hate when you
bring the portable kitchen table
when you're at the airport in their life
you can't bring these items on a plane
it's like a weed whacker in a kitchen
table you know right probably Colin
tried to bring a weed whacker onto a
plane as one of his 52 items you know
it's funny when he sent me that video of
Colin where he just kind of talked about
you talked about your minimalist
lifestyle I just remember thinking like
it's the same thing I'm like huh man I
want to like travel all the time but I
totally saw how you were able to use
minimalism to free yourself of I don't
know those those anchors that keep us
kind of at bay yeah and that's the it's
a really vital component of that type of
thinking that philosophy is that you can
use it for whatever it's not a matter
where you know you you're a minimalist
now you have to live out of a bag right
that was my priority was travel and so
literally anything that I owned above
and beyond what I could fit into
carry-on luggage was something that was
weighing me down and keeping me from
that thing that was most important and
you guys thankfully were able to come
into it and say well actually I have
other things that are most important to
me and then use it to prioritize your
things that's I think that was the thing
that was often a misconception about
people who were especially in them that
minimal space 2009-2010 it was a bunch
of single guys who were traveling a lot
and but that's because the people who
wrote about it were single guys who
travel a lot also in the blogosphere
like it was an early era for the the
tech thing too like we didn't have a
bunch of podcast we didn't have a lot of
blogs either it was still a relatively
new thing and so the people who were
already interested in that space the
people with the biggest megaphones
essentially was a very narrow
demographic who had very similar
interests and so it wasn't super
representative us up to like when I
started with you I'm like oh that's cool
but I don't think it's for me but then
you led me to like leopa bout or Cortney
Carver and like people who were no
actual normal people and a cyborg but we
got some questions here today but before
we dive in just real quick it's funny
what I saw Colin do is he was like he
mentioned earlier how he wanted to
travel that was a priority and I looked
at my priorities and I'm like okay what
do I want my number-one priority to be
and at the time that was to reclaim some
of my time so minimalism helped me to
basically
just ask that question like with what I
was doing with all of my resources my
money my time my attention like are
those serving this one purpose for you
was traveling for me was getting my time
back and minimalism just ups you cut out
the rest the I'm rated I've in our first
question today is from Cory Cory is a
patreon subscriber from Arizona Thank
You Cory I know that part of the
American dream is to own your own home
do you still see owning a home as a
worthy goal I've paid off close to
100,000 and debt and I'm now debt-free
and it seems the next step after my
emergency fund is to save up for a home
I feel that home prices are overvalued
since most people go with a 30-year
mortgage and if 30-year mortgages were
not an option home prices would be way
cheaper I also don't enjoy my current
work situation enough to be stuck with a
mortgage it gives me a feeling of
claustrophobia but I always hear that
owning a home long-term is better than
renting Ryan I think the depends what he
means by long-term ultimately on a long
long term you're gonna be dead right on
a long enough timeline yeah we're all
dead yeah we like to uplift our
listeners yeah yeah I think it really
depends on what your objectives are like
for Colin right now wouldn't make sense
for you to own a home necessarily
although it could you you could rent it
out I I own a home back in Dayton Ohio
as a rental property and I rent it out
to someone and and that is truly an
investment I tend not to look at your
the home you live in as an investment so
much ultimately it can become an asset
for you but I think we conflate the two
investments are different from home
ownership usually in fact home ownership
is often a blessing it is a burden for
you right it absolutely can be and it
can limit you to because then you have
your your resources tied up in this one
asset which is susceptible to damage
which is something that you have to take
care of that you have to continue to
invest in and it kind of depends to
whether you want it as a something that
will grow and monetary value or if
you're looking at it as a practical
asset that you're then able to utilize
and get more out of your every moment of
every day because if it amplifies the
way that you're living your life and
you're happier as a consequence that
potentially adds more value behind
then it makes a lot more sense because
you're actually using it whereas if it's
something that's monetary then the the
digits in in place in the amount that
you're spending make a whole lot more it
it feeds into the rationale behind it a
whole lot more yeah Cory first off
congratulations I paying off a hundred
thousand dollars a debt that is freakin
awesome
the one thing that Cory said that stood
out to me was he talks about how it
seems like this is the logical next step
I always hear people say that owning a
home is better so you know we often talk
about getting getting behind the Y like
really understanding why we want to do
anything in our lives but especially
when making major decisions like this so
Cory the question is why do you want to
own home is it because you feel like
that is the logical next step is it
because you hear people say that owning
a home is better or is it because maybe
he wants to you know plant some roots
and he wants to hang out for five to ten
years I agree with his point of he is in
this job that he doesn't love that he
kind of hates and having a 30-year
mortgage is gonna make him feel
claustrophobic it should make him feel
claustrophobic I don't think anyone
should aspire to have a 30-year mortgage
it's we're one of two countries where
that is the norm and in fact what Chris
Hogan when he was on our podcast
informed us now they're starting to do
40 year mortgages with some banks and at
most if you really wanted to buy a house
you should have at least 20% down I
think ideally 50% down and you should
try to do a 15-year mortgage and try to
pay it off in seven if you can here or
you can save up enough money to
eventually pay cash for a property and
then it does become an investment for
you because you can rent it out as
opposed because if you don't actually
own the home then it's not homeownership
its home borrow ship until you you
actually own the the property yourself
and so what I'm hearing here is it's
sort of his discontent mmm that is I
there's a lot of discontent I feel like
I'm aspiring toward as you said right
he's aspiring towards someone else's
idea the American Dream we're living the
but he needs to identify what is his
dream yeah buying a home for the sake of
well I want to put money towards a
mortgage rather than you know throw
money out the window with rent that is
not always the best advice right right
well there just the opportunity cost in
terms of money but also in terms of then
being stuck in a place even if you
decide five years from now that you want
to be somewhere else the opportunity
cost is literally everything else that
you could be doing with that money
everything else that you could be doing
with the time that you had to invest in
that job that you don't particularly
like to get that money and then all of
the other things that you could be doing
elsewhere but you have to stick around
because you've got so much invested in
this asset yeah in this one particular
location yeah real quick what what would
be positive about owning a house is yes
you are you do end up owning an asset
eventually usually not if you're on a
30-year mortgage because you you you
don't end up owning a home you end up
selling it beforehand it's a shame that
that's the norm in like that is the
30-year mortgage like that is the norm I
mean I don't know what percentage of
home loans are 30-year mortgages but
just because that's the norm or the
average lake that doesn't make it right
I mean you know we come common yeah and
it's fun like we always talk about how
you know with this freedom we have in
America comes a great responsibility and
you know taking on a 30-year mortgage
that's a huge it's a huge decision huge
responsibility another positive is you
have control over the space so if you do
want to remodel the kitchen or something
like the apartment I'm renting here in
Los Angeles
I couldn't just I'm gonna remodel the
kitchen first off it'd be a really bad
idea for me to do that because I'd be
spending my own money to improve someone
else's asset so you would have more
control of your space which is which is
great on the downsides I can think of a
bunch of downside the cost is a downside
because we think of like oh yeah it's a
mortgage payment it's roughly the same
as my rent well you also have to think
about property taxes and if it's a condo
there all the HOA fees which you have
certainly experienced in the past also
things break a water heater's break
dishwashers break sometimes there's a
crack in the wall or what something
happens in the foundation things go
wrong with a house and if you rent
then you make a phone call and say hey
if something went wrong with this
property that's a great that's a great
point like Cory think about what the
advantages are to not owning a home yes
you can make a phone call and have a
water heater replaced without forking
out the money to do it yourself or
you've got the freedom to pick up and
move I mean that's what does Derek's
ever say I see the one that talks about
how he pays renting is is buying the
option to move yeah whenever you want
yeah yeah so so basically Cory I think
you've to figure out what is appropriate
for you and for your lifestyle what is
your American dream what what is living
the dream look like to you and you know
I think we'll help you with that I'm
gonna send you a copy of our book
minimalism it really outlines the the
five foundational values because we all
know this if you don't know what your
values are then you're really not gonna
know the direction and you want to go to
pursue your dream so podcast Shawn if
you could reach out the core and send
him a copy of minimalism the audiobook
version if you like our podcast you like
the audiobook version or if you want the
book book or the e-book then we'll be
happy to send those to you as well but I
think it's important to know what your
values are so you can determine what is
appropriate for your life yeah the
problem is is that if you don't know
your values then you start to look at
other people and take on their values
right and they may not be yours and all
of a sudden you've gone down the wrong
path for three years five years and
you're like wait a minute I'm living
someone else's ideal of our idea of a
perfect life in the the right investment
for somebody can be the wrong investment
for everybody else essentially yeah you
could tweet that podcast Shawn Ryan what
time is it you know what time it is it
it's time for our lightning round where
we answer questions from social media
and did we do we're at the minimalists
on Facebook Twitter and Instagram we
have Collin here he's at Collin is my
name on all the relevant social media
platforms and they're in the lightning
round column this is where we do our
best to answer every question with just
a short shareable less than 140
character response we're real minimal
that's right no but actually what we
really do is we just monitor on a bit
until we come up with something pithy we
call them minimal Maxim's and Shawn puts
them in the show notes
yeas and if yeah Sean makes it look
really beautiful in post and then social
Jess she puts it on minimal Maxim's comm
for us as well so all of our pithy
answers are collected in one place
what's our first question Ryan our first
question is from Alan what defines
freedom these days from a psychological
physical financial and material
perspective what are the key steps to
take to begin to realize that sense of
freedom while earning enough to provide
for a family
so what's freedom for you Colin it's
gonna be different for every single
person that you ask totally agree for me
what's really important and what I try
to invest in and more so every year I
think is making sure that I have the
option to do the type of work that I
care about to be around the type of
people that I want to surround myself
with to have the types of experiences
that I want to have and importantly and
this is something that won't be the same
for everybody but for me I like being
able to invest myself in projects that
won't necessarily earn me money and
that's not something that you
necessarily just get from society right
off the bat it's not something that
you're told you're supposed to pursue
but I find that being able to invest
myself fully as if it's a job that I'm
doing full-time to pay the rent being
able to invest myself in that way and
stuff that may only pay off in terms of
experience in terms of me getting to see
things from a slightly different angle
but won't necessarily pay off in terms
of money in having that having the
option to do these things and to to do
all the next row extrapolations of that
- to do it from wherever I happen to
want to go being able to work with the
type of people I want to work with the
freedom to kind of recalibrate things
and put together different shapes of
lifestyle whenever I want that to me is
freedom by my standard certain
discipline involved in that and because
I think sometimes we think about freedom
is like doing whatever you want whenever
you want but that's not real freedom
that is tyranny weight when my
five-year-old daughter if I'd let her do
whatever she wants whenever she wants
she'd be dead in a week for sure you
have to keep on building infrastructure
and for me the way that I imagine it
just visually is it's almost like a
framework like a scaffolding and then
within that scaffolding I can bill
whatever I want at any point and take it
apart and put it back together but
there's a skeleton on it there's a
structure there that keeps things that
that provides me with a foundation in
three dimensions that allows me to build
whatever I want so it's kind of the
equivalent of preparing yourself for
whatever you might want to do in the
future rather than preparing yourself
for one specific future that's what I
tend to think about there's something
there with freedom and discipline
because like you said like we feel like
freedom is doing whatever we want but
that leads to chaos yeah so having to
discipline or have discipline have
self-discipline or to have to have to
force ourselves to do things doesn't
really feel like freedom but that's what
but it Jaco willing as a discipline
equals freedom right and that's
ultimately what he's saying there is you
have to have that scaffolding you have
to have these sort of structures in
place so that you can do what you want
but within the confines of it not it's
not always your life is not a
comfortable life the colonist comforts
but those discomforts I perceive them as
valuable frictions right not everybody
would but I think part of it too part of
being able to have that discipline over
time is recognizing one the difficult
things that are not enjoyable are
valuable and as a consequence you can
take a certain type of pleasure in that
and accomplishing those things but also
being able to kind of recalibrate your
perception of even those frictions and
discomforts and saying this is enjoyable
in a way how novel and unique this
uncomfortable experience happens to be
that stoic mentality that you can't
control what happens around you but you
can control your perception of it how
you respond to it there's a lot of that
that goes into this I think I'm gonna
give a pithy answer here our freedom
corresponds directly with our ability to
walk away from anything reach that's one
thing I really learned from you column
was your ability to walk away even from
situations that are going relatively
well I what people were perceived to be
going well liked it when I was in the
corporate roles I first discovered you
and you know we've become really good
friends since then but when I realized
back then is like oh like Colin's
walking away from stuff that he doesn't
hate necessarily he doesn't wait till
something blows up to walk away from it
he's walking towards something else
and during our patreon episode today I'm
actually gonna read from this essay that
I wrote a while ago called the things we
were prepared to walk away from and I
think office it's perceived to be to be
cold at first right did
yeah when you've walked away from things
in the past it's it's actually cuz
you're walking towards something that is
increasing your freedom yeah yeah I've
actually had a lot of people look at
what I have done over the years and say
so what are you running from they
haven't caught me yet what are you
talking about but no I mean that's the
thing though like it can look like
running away because that's our
perception that if you are trying to
change dramatically if you're
recalibrating your compass in some
dramatic way well that probably means
that something went totally arrise
something blew up behind you and you're
trying to escape when in reality ideally
we're always kind of looking toward
other possibilities and other options
and we're always looking for
opportunities to make valuable pivots
whether they're small or very large and
then preparing ourselves over time so
that when we want to make those pivots
we are in the right position
psychologically financially everything
else so that we can do it without it
being this crazy risk that might destroy
everything and hurt people instead it's
something that's just kind of a crazy
personal risk and a little bit of a a
it's devastating to the status quo and
your expectations and habits but
otherwise it's something that doesn't
cause any harm to you individually the
thing with the corporate world for me is
when I walked away you really helped me
realize like oh it's gonna be okay like
I don't I didn't think I was ever going
to you do this whole minimalism thing
and everything else was going to be all
this but I realized like no I could just
write fiction and make twenty three
thousand dollars a year working at a
coffee shop I'm gonna be okay a barista
or something yeah that one side was that
was that was my my main objective was to
do that and so when I got sidetracked
yeah well I didn't hate my corporate
career either like it was a six out of
ten for me but and I was really good at
it that was actually the problem it was
so hard to walk away from something
you're good at and you don't hate but I
also wasn't passionate about it it
wasn't my dream anymore
yeah my pet the answer it's funny when
we when Josh and I prepare for this so
we have the the Twitter question and
then we just put down our pithy answers
and I don't look at your answers because
I don't want it to influence my answer
but I literally wrote something
basically along the same lines of like
freedom is the ability to walk away from
anything so here's my second pithy
answer really debt-free is the new
American Dream and what I mean by that
Alan is debt is one of the biggest
chains that we that we chained ourselves
with so if you are currently not
debt-free I would encourage you to like
take that as the first step to to
becoming free one of the better
decisions I made before I left LA yeah
it untethered you in a lot of ways
psychologically and otherwise right
because there's no you don't to force
yourself to go to that job you hate you
don't have to yeah it takes it takes a
lot of hard work to get there I don't
want to undermine how difficult it is to
become debt-free but it's totally
possible but it's an achievable dream
absolutely requires that discipline and
hard work for sure all right looks like
we got one more question for the
lightning round we do it is from Aaron
do you feel like you've met more
meaningful people by traveling if so how
has it affected you compared to before
you were traveling well my quick pit the
answer to this one is our perspectives
shape our worldview our worldview shapes
our lives that's one thing I when we're
talking to like big crowds of people
when we go on tour it you know there's a
joke I office says like there are three
things I hate travel crowds of people
and public speaking but it's not that I
actually hate those things it's putting
myself in an uncomfortable situation
that isn't actually going to be
devastating to me but that's the place
from which I grow the most yeah and I
think traveling is has enabled you to
grow in ways that you you probably
didn't anticipate when you first set out
to do it full of valuable frictions like
just things that test you and push you
right beyond what you're comfortable
with like that's what I tend to look for
it's like going to the gym you don't
want to like completely destroy yourself
to the point where you injure yourself
but you also don't want to do something
so easy and familiar that you don't have
any gains from it you want to do
something just beyond what you were
capable of and comfortable with before
and that includes meeting people like
you I don't think that you must travel
to meet interesting people and have
valuable really
chips but you can't really help but meet
a bunch of people who will challenge
your your sense of the way that the
world works when you travel so it makes
it a little bit easier but you can
actually do the same thing this is
something that I wanted to test when I
lived in Wichita and Memphis came back
to the u.s. to explore some place that
was more familiar with more familiar
tropes and culture I wanted to make sure
I could do some of the same stuff
without travelling rapidly and anywhere
you go you can do this it just requires
that you put in a little bit more effort
if a lot of the structure is already
familiar yeah it's awesome pithy let me
it looks like you haven't edited yeah
and I don't have the edited version can
I read your your edited version of them
I hit the answer thanks man all right my
pithy answer is to live life to the
fullest
we must seek different perspectives no
matter how uncomfortable they make us
and you know to your point Colin like
you have to go out and you have to have
your beliefs and your values challenged
a little bit like I grew up in this
bubble of you know being a part of
Jehovah's Witnesses and anyone who
challenged anything I had these walls
built up that really prevented me from
being happy honestly yeah and yeah it's
it is it is it is truly a pleasure to be
able to travel around and get all
different types of perspectives but yeah
you've got a you've got a have a diverse
a diverse group of people to bounce
those values and beliefs off of yeah I
don't remember who said it but strong
beliefs lightly held I think is a really
good policy because then being open to
changing your mind is one of the most
intellectually honest things any person
through oh absolutely yeah we're meeting
with our friend TK Coleman after this um
you and I were talking about this
yesterday he is he steal man's instead
of straw Manning organ he steal man's
both sides of an argument because he
knows in fact he'll argue with you even
he has the same belief as you he'll
argue against your belief in order to
make his own bit stronger and I'm
getting a wrap-up sign from Sean so it
looks like we have several more surprise
questions to talk about today I want to
talk about oh we're going to answer some
questions here about whether minimalism
actually works for poor people that's a
question we have we also have questions
about
new products that help fulfill the
American dream about whether the
American Dream is still relevant and I
want to chat with Colin about his
curiosity for everything he seems to be
one of the most curious people I know
also I have a bit of a health update for
you all as well I found out I got a
really bad ecoli overgrowth when we were
in Brazil last September and that's
that's really what has led to the last
six-month spiral I saw you eating
bunches of romaine lettuce a couple
weeks ago definitely not I drank some
water down in Brazil and it's got some
tests back so we'll talk about that as
well on the maximal episode also Ryan
and I had the strangest but oddly fun
DMV experience yesterday yeah and we can
at least talk about that talk about
turning a bad situation into something
that we're hilarity ensued where I think
we almost got kicked out of the deal and
if you all want to hear all of that you
can listen to this week's maximal
episode available exclusively on patreon
that's right you're currently listening
to our weekly minimal episode but each
week Ryan and I record an entirely
different long-form maximal episode on
the minimalists private podcast which
gives us the private space we need to
discuss topics we don't usually discuss
in public plus we don't wear pants on
that episode I mean we only videotape
ourselves from the waist up so yeah it's
mainly for us plus patreon is the best
way for us to fund this podcast to keep
it a hundred percent advertisement free
when you subscribe to the minimalist
private podcast on patreon you'll
receive a personal link so that our
maximal episodes play in your favorite
podcast app you also get access to our
entire back catalogue of more than 100
private podcast episodes find all the
details and all the good stuff including
an additional long-form podcast episode
every week over at the minimalists com
slash support Ryan what else you got for
us this week being informed is more
important than ever so I want to
encourage everyone to read more and get
informed and now here are some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners
hello this is Larry from Brazil and I
would like to share my experience with
living Facebook I once had 5,000
Facebook friends because I believed this
would bring me more business it did not
these people were collecting
like one more pin for the Pinterest
brother friends as was I so I started to
unfriend them one by one and once I got
to only people I actually knew I still
had over 400 friends there's no way that
keeping in touch with 400 people would
add value to my life so I decided to
ignore the potential backlash and then
friend until I was down to close friends
only and guess what there was zero
backlash because these people did not
actually care about me as much as I did
not actually care about them the next
step seemed so obvious to me all my
close friends have my numbers so why not
limit these interactions to actual
conversations and delete Facebook
altogether it's been over a year and I
never looked back hey guys so I have
been trying to live a more sustainable
and ethical life and that is how I came
across your podcast on many episodes and
especially the one about clothing you
guys discussed buying things responsibly
and suggested a few companies that share
your values I wanted to share how this
can be applied not just to things but
also with everyday consumable items that
obviously you cannot buy second-hand
such as cleaning supplies beauty bath
and body items skincare and many other
many of us Center companies that you
find in stores don't have the most
sustainable or ethical practices most
cleaning or beauty brands use dirty palm
oil others use harsh chemicals and many
other things so this has led me to
discover and support smaller businesses
so for example I buy natural the other
end lotions and all my bath items from
an Etsy shop there are many out there I
just pick the one closest to me and it's
all natural and homemade I buy my
dishwashing and laundry detergent from
drops that spelled Dro
PPS it gets shipped to my house and you
can look on their website about their
awesome social and environmental
responsibility it is also plastic free
it's just little pods that come in a box
my favorite
Brande is my toilet paper and paper
towel brand
they're called who gives a crap it is a
bit more pricey but they donate 50
percent of their profits to building
toilets in the third world in
third-world countries
we're lack of sewage systems effects
health and many children die from this
so it is a great way to help by doing
something as simple as well wiping your
butt plus their emails are always funny
with the toilet puns and they make
reports showing their latest donations
and impacts those are just a few of my
favourite alternatives are many more out
there if you do your research so if you
can don't use focus responsible
purchasing to close and things but also
to everyday things alright Joe thanks
again to Colin right for joining us
today make sure you check out his
podcast it's called let's know things
and find him on the web exiled lifestyle
calm you can read any of his 34 books 35
we're in the neighborhood okay
he lost count I think he writes a book
for every year he's been alive been
writing one book a year since he was
zero the early ones are pretty rough
check him out exile lifestyle calm and
real quick four right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalist swell sort of
it's a one-person we work with Jessica
Lynn Williams some of you know her as
social Jess she started her own social
media business she's helping folks be
more intentional with their social media
especially businesses or brands who want
to communicate more effectively aren't
worried about I need to gain 700,000
followers but how do i effectively
communicate with people yeah in a way
that adds value to their liability over
quantities really good yeah she's really
helped us add value using our own
creations and our own words and photos
but curating in a way she's really a
curator of social eighty-four let's weed
out something and it's like you know at
Ryan Nicodemus and I'm like I don't even
remember saying I am so good so if
you're interested in getting some help
with your social media or you know
someone who is her website is
intentional dot social his name of her
website if you have a question comment
or minimalism tip for our podcast leave
us a voice
four zero six two one nine seven eight
three nine or send a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists comm you can
comment on this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimalist if you want our
show notes in your inbox you can sign up
for our email list over at the
minimalists comm which will also sign
you up for our simple Sunday emails each
week and of course will never send you
spam because that stuff's gross for
added value this week david gray is back
yeah he just his new album just came out
it's his first album in five years it's
called
gold and a brass age I think the album
is really a it's like this portrait of
ethereal maturity he's become this
mature singer-songwriter who has grown
with age and the the album itself is
it's more sort of laid-back than his
previous album that I know you really
enjoy so let's play you out today with
the lead off track from gold and a brass
age it's called the sapling and if you
leave here today with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time minimus